da bin ich ja endlich mal gescheite musik richtig gescheite musik kann mir meistens
nicht machen weil monka toss im stream bei the way an sich soll das game auch
relativ nice sein jetzt jetzt müsste ich noch eine runde so wikinger death metal zeug anmachen
aber das geht ja nicht weil monka toss machst du nix bitte den archiv fliegen links und habe ich
dann archiv link ach das gibt es ja mehr tatsächlich ja es ist gut gut dass du es gesagt
hast wie bearbeitet man das überhaupt gescheit hier einfach nur archiv weg machen safe neben
ich redirected wir
nicht redirected das muss auch https sein dass es funktioniert nicht http editiert mal kurz
https jetzt stimmt's nicht redirected probier's aus ach so ja mit https wird redirected ok das
kann sein aber das war noch ein link auf http http archiv das wird nicht redirected ja jetzt
wird nicht redirected ja jetzt wird nicht redirected ja jetzt wird nicht redirected ja jetzt
jetzt jetzt geht's an mit http ging es nicht also habe ich immer ausprobiert nicht funktionieren
das ist baro wieder theoretisch theoretisch musst du auch auf http nicht antworten sondern der
webserver sollte automatisch redirecten ja ist ja auch leider meistens so aber dass er baro ist
genug beschäftigt da muss ich mit irgendwelchen nervigen schüler herumschlagen ich hätte so
keinen bock drauf lehrer zu sein leute ich sag's euch lehrer ist glaube ich so ziemlich
keinen bock drauf lehrer ist glaube ich so ziemlich
keinen bock drauf lehrer ist glaube ich so ziemlich das abartigste was ich mir vorstellen kann ich
das abartigste was ich mir vorstellen kann ich
das abartigste was ich mir vorstellen kann ich würde würde jetzt mal etwas würdet ihr
würde würde jetzt mal etwas würdet ihr
würde würde jetzt mal etwas würdet ihr wirklich würde dir freiwillig lehrer
wirklich würde dir freiwillig lehrer
wirklich würde dir freiwillig lehrer werden
werden
werden also ja ich weiß es gibt manche die das
also ja ich weiß es gibt manche die das
also ja ich weiß es gibt manche die das machen aber ich kann das nicht
machen aber ich kann das nicht
machen aber ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen männer er sie im leben
nachvollziehen männer er sie im leben
nicht. Hey, ich hab
keine Ahnung, was denn Simbaro
da reizt, dass der Lehrer werden will, Alter.
Aber gut, hey, ich mein,
irgendeiner muss es ja machen, ne?
Irgendeiner, ich mein,
wenn's keiner macht, ist er auch doof.
Was los, heute Ärger drauf? Was?
Heute gut drauf, wurde Ärger...
Wieso?
Ich hör noch... Ups. Ich hör
normalerweise
den Größteil meiner Zeit, wenn
ich Musik anhab, sowas hier in der Richtung.
Aber ich kann halt meistens nix im Stream
anmachen.
Ja, ich weiß. Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich kenn das.
Ich weiß, dass man in WOTS...
Das muss ich mir echt unbedingt
mal angucken, dass in WOTS
die Musik ausgetauscht wird.
Ich mach jetzt aber trotzdem ein bisschen was weniger
Anstrengendes an. Okay, jetzt vielleicht...
Wir gehen jetzt vielleicht nicht von
ähm...
Hellsinger Ost zu
Song and Smiles Happy and
Upbeat Nintendo Music.
Das Kontrast ist vielleicht ein bisschen
zu hart, oder?
Lieber nicht.
Das klingt schon ein bisschen wupp, wupp, wupp an.
Moin, Probearbeiten
war heut heftig.
Ja, warum? Erzähl.
Du hast irgendwas gesagt, wo du dich beworben hast.
Ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Du hast gestern was geschrieben.
Du hattest gestern irgendwas geschrieben.
Nee, Nintendo Musik...
Game Musi... Ach, Def...
Ach, Def Ops und Windows Zeug.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen, dass das heftig war.
Ich mein, Windows alleine
ist ja schon abfuck genug.
Nee, Gameplay muss...
Also, Gaming Musik geht eigentlich immer in Streams.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Keck, wait.
Die haben aber ein geiles Deployment gerade.
Und ich frag mich, wie man Windows geil deployt.
Also, wisst ihr, was die
geilste... Soll ich euch mal zeigen, was die
geilste Variante ist, um Windows zu deployen?
Debian downloaden.
Das ist die beste Art,
wie man Windows deployt.
Also, haben die da auch Windows auf Servern?
Oh, girls.
Haben die da auch Windows
auf Servern? Wow.
Ach, du Scheiße.
No,
God!
No, God, please,
no! Fick dich weg,
du Robo-Fürst.
Sonst gastriere ich dir
die Eier.
Alter, 800 Windows
Server. Ich kann mir
ja kaum was Schlimmeres vorstellen.
Aber,
jetzt mal unabhängig davon,
weil ich das nicht mag.
Also, nicht, dass der Job schlecht sein muss.
Ich könnte mir bloß nicht vorstellen.
Windows Server, meine Güte.
Meine Güte. Also, wir hatten zu Spitzenzeiten...
Wartet mal.
Ich mach mal
ein bisschen was
verträglicheres für die Leute im Stream an.
Ähm...
Wupp, wupp, wupp. Ja, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Sehr gut.
Da kann man nichts schief machen. Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Also, auf der alten Arbeit
hatten wir so zu...
Spitzenzeiten
glaube ich so...
Ja, 3000
Linux-Systeme ungefähr.
Ich rechne VMs mit, ja.
Muss ich dazu sagen, in dem Fall.
Also, halt logische Server.
Ich glaube
in der Spitzenzeit so um 3
vielleicht auch
ein bisschen mehr, so 3000
Linux-Systeme
zu Spitzenzeiten...
Und das war schon eklig.
Das alles
irgendwie den Überblick zu behalten.
Und wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, dass nur ein Bruchteil
davon Windows ist...
Boah, da würde ich ja durchdrehen.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Nicht mal...
Ja, so ist es.
Selbst Microsoft hat ihren Kram mittlerweile auf Linux.
Aha.
Ach so,
die Anwendung ist von euch. Ja, gut.
Wir haben mittlerweile sogar
Windows-Code. Ja, aber das ist Fake.
Welcher Fake Hyper-V-Müll
unter der Haube, oder?
Ist Docker für Windows nicht Hyper-V unter der Haube,
was den kompletten Sinn von Docker
also generell von Containern irgendwie
in Frage stellt, wenn es dann doch wieder
VMs sind?
Na gut, die einfache Handhabung mit
Docker als CLI-Tool und so
bleibt ja weiterhin bestehen.
Aber so auf größeren
Maßstäben ist es ziemlich
unsinnig. Ja, ich weiß,
ist ja nicht schlimm.
Weil ich das ein bisschen schlecht mache, muss das
kein schlechter Job sein, beziehungsweise muss das auch
keine schlechte Arbeit sein.
Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass man auch im Windows-Umfeld
spaßige und interessante
Sachen machen kann.
Vielleicht, ja. Also ich hätte
bloß keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, nee, also wichtig ist ja, dass es dir
gefällt und was dich
so von der Technologie auch anspricht.
Nur weil, ich sag's ja immer
wieder im Stream, nur weil ich was kacke finde,
heißt ja nicht wirklich, dass es automatisch auch
universal, global
kacke sein muss.
Außer C++ vielleicht.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Hast du da einen
Probearbeitstag gemacht, weil du noch überlegst, ob
du unterschreibst? Oder bist du dir schon mehr oder
weniger sicher, dass du unterschreibst?
Vieles ist Hyper-V. Tatsächlich, man
muss allerdings gucken,
also, nö, einfach nur so.
Man muss aber auch gucken,
vor allem, weil Windows 10 das Emoji nicht kann.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Fuck. Ja, man muss auch gucken,
wenn man Hyper-V einschaltet und dann
bei Windows 11, falls ihr euch fragt,
warum manche Sachen nicht gehen, wenn
ihr Hyper-V oder den Hyper-V
Workload, nennt sich das glaube ich bei Windows,
keine Ahnung, was da bei Microsoft wieder los ist,
überlegst, ja.
Aber scheint ja ein ganz guter Job
zu sein. Wenn die automatisiertes Deployment
haben, sogar auf Kundensysteme, das ist
seltene Kombination,
ja, dass sie das auch erlauben, dann
scheint der Laden ja schon mal nicht so schlecht zu sein.
Was wollte ich sagen? Genau.
Wenn ihr unter Windows 10 Hyper-V
aktiviert und so, ist gar kein Problem. Wenn ihr
übrigens, da müsst ihr aufpassen, kann ich euch aus eigener Erfahrung
sagen, wenn ihr Windows 11 habt
und aktiviert Hyper-V,
dann aktiviert Windows unter der Haube
auch noch irgendwelche
Isolations-Security-Features,
die wiederum dazu
führen, dass
VMware Workstation nicht funktioniert.
Ein großes Problem bei
VMware Workstation ist und
gibt es anscheinend jetzt auch ein Update,
okay, vielleicht ist es mit dem Update gefixt,
aber ich glaube nicht, ist, dass
wenn ihr diesen Hyper-V Workload aktiviert
habt und VMware Workstation
startet, dann
gibt es Probleme, dass
die Inputs, das Tastatur-Input
und Keyboard-Input
laggy as fuck ist.
Ich habe noch nicht genau verstanden, wie das ist.
Ah ja, und es gibt Probleme beim
Scheduling von den Tasks.
Das heißt, VMware Workstation
läuft nicht richtig, wenn der Hyper-V
Workload aktiviert ist. Allerdings auch nur,
wenn
ihr Windows 11 habt. Wenn ihr
Windows 10 habt, ist es wiederum kein Problem
und dann funktioniert es. Übrigens, wisst ihr, was mir
auch aufgefallen ist? Da muss ich jetzt mal
Darkseid, du als krasser Windows-Hacker,
du weißt es doch bestimmt. Guck mal,
Microsoft hat gesagt,
die Uhr in Windows
10, in Windows 11 darf
keine Sekundenanzeigen mehr haben.
Wie bekomme ich wieder Sekundenanzeigen?
Windows 11 hatte das by the way noch.
Du konntest bei Windows 11 hier draufklicken und
dann hattest du hier eine Anzeige
in Sekunden.
Wie bekomme ich wieder Sekunden in meine Uhr?
Welcher Volldepp
bei Microsoft hat sich denn wieder gedacht?
Ah, Sekunden. Ne, das ist kein
kein agiles
bleeding edge, nice
Windows Features. Bloated.
Bloated Sekunden, Alter.
Selbstwitz
mit Bordmittel nicht.
Überlegt euch mal. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Es hat allen Ernstes,
wirklich, ohne Scheiß,
es hat allen Ernstes bei Microsoft irgendjemand
gedacht, Sekunden
bei einer Uhr braucht man nicht.
Wie kommt man auf die Idee,
dass eine Uhr nicht mal optional
...
Sekunden, Mann!
Wie dumm!
Wie dumm
ist das eigentlich, Mann?
Keine Sekunden in der Uhr.
Das ist so hängengeblieben, was die da
basteln, Alter. Ich weiß nicht,
was das soll.
Ich kann ja über die meisten Sachen
immer hinwegsehen. Solange sie
nicht gängeln mit irgendeinem
Scheiß. Und das fuckt mich halt
bei Windows 11 so richtig ab.
Ja, es hat schon seine Vorteile,
aber es kann mir doch keiner erzählen
so nach dem Motto, Max, du hast
einfach nur noch nicht
die neue Designstrategie verstanden.
Das ist
Usability pur ohne
Sekunden. Nein, ich will Sekundenanzeigen
haben. Wisst ihr zum Beispiel, warum ich
Sekundenanzeigen haben will?
Dass ich weiß, wann ich schon mal
in ein Teams-Meeting reinjoinen kann
und wann nicht. Ja, ich will meistens
nicht in das Teams-Meeting reinjoinen
als Allererster, weil dann
steht immer da, Max startet
die Besprechung und dann kommen die Leute rein und sagen
Ah ja, Max auch schon da.
Erste Mal
fünf Minuten auf Smalltalk halten, was nicht schlimm ist.
Die Leute bei mir sind wirklich alle
super nett. Kann ich nichts sagen. Und das sage ich als jemand,
der andere Menschen in der Regel nicht mag.
Aber trotzdem, ich gehe dann meistens
immer pünktlich halt so kurz bevor
die Uhr umspringt rein.
Was ist das für eine Kacke, Mann?
Warum ist da keine Sekundenanzeige?
Da könnte ich mich so richtig reinsteigern
und mich den ganzen Tag drüber aufregen.
Und wahrscheinlich, weil die Tasklist ja
irgend so komische kastrierte
OWP
Anwendung ist, kann man wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal mehr irgendwelche
gescheiten Änderungen daran vornehmen.
Unter Windows
95, 98, ME
2000,
XP,
und wahrscheinlich
auch noch Vista
und wahrscheinlich sogar
bis Windows 7, inklusive
Windows 7
konnte man ja nahezu alles mit der
Taskleiste machen und modden. Also bis
inklusive XP auf jeden Fall.
Ich meine, XP hat ja noch quasi die Oldschool
Windows 95 Leiste unter der Haube.
Und ab Vista wurde es dann ein bisschen
anders. Ab Vista gab es ja noch diese komische Suche
hier und sowas. Allerdings trotzdem,
ich meine,
Sekunden, hier ist, guck mal,
hier ist ja sogar noch Platz.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre hier kein Platz.
Guckt mal, hier ist Platz.
Man könnte fast annehmen,
hier würden genau die Sekunden reinpassen,
wenn man will.
Aber man will ja nicht.
Hat ja kein Bock bei Microsoft.
Es geht um die Performance, ja klar,
natürlich.
Die Performance ist bestimmt voll im Arsch,
wenn die Uhr auf einmal Sekunden anzeigt.
Ich glaube, das bringt eindeutig
meinen
ähm, meinen,
wo sehe ich denn jetzt, hat jetzt Windows
umgeschaltet, wo sieht man jetzt hier nochmal,
ich hasse Windows, das geht mir auf den Sack.
Wo sehe ich denn hier meine, meine,
wo ist denn meine CPU-Anzahl
auf einmal hin? Wo ist da doppelt,
achso, ich sollte vielleicht,
ich sollte vielleicht CPU drücken, anstatt Memory.
Ja, also Sekunden,
Sekunden in der Uhr
werden garantiert performance-technisch
mein, äh,
zwei und drei, also
24 Kern, 64 GB
RAM-Rechner,
4090 RTX-Rechner überfordern.
Ich glaube, das schafft er nicht.
Ich glaube, Sekunden in der Uhr, da wäre komplett vorbei.
Da kann, da kann jeder,
Prime 95, alle Benchmarks
können einpacken, Sekunden in der Uhr.
Jetzt vorbei.
Ausgelastet.
100 Prozent.
F.
Leute, soll ich mal was sagen?
Guck mal da.
Ich habe keine Sekunden eingeblendet.
Seht ihr das?
Und warum habe ich keine Sekunden eingeblendet?
Weil mich die Sekunden-Anzeige
in der Uhr nervt.
Aber ich will die Sekunden-Anzeige im
Overlay haben, so wie unter Windows 10.
Das ist okay.
Ja, hier habe ich auch nicht, hier habe ich auch nicht eingeblendet.
Aber hier kann man schnell aufs Terminal switchen
und gucken, ja.
Äh, ich aktualisiere tatsächlich anscheinend nicht
sekundenweise, war mir auch neu.
Habe ich, habe ich vergessen.
Vielleicht sollten wir das gerade mal schnell ändern.
Wo ist das?
Vielleicht sollte man das einfach mal kurz
ändern. Guck mal hier.
Intervall, wo ist hier?
Date-Time-Format.
Okay.
%s sind das Seconds?
Äh.
Nein.
Doch.
Das habe ich richtig gemacht.
Jetzt haben wir auch wieder Sekunden.
So muss das sein.
Es kann so einfach sein.
Man trägt hier das Format einfach
was man haben will und schon
hat man Sekunden, aber nicht unter Windows.
Ja.
Ist um 3% angestiegen
auf einem Kern.
Von 24.
Selbst wenn es 3 Sekunden
wären, würde mich auch nicht
jucken. Habt ihr übrigens gelesen, es gibt
jetzt eine 30 GB
Festplatte und die hat richtig
geile Technik.
Ähm. Die hat nämlich,
wie heißt das?
Hammerl hat das. Hammerl.
Hammerl. Das ist
passt mal auf, das
ist ähm
Heated
Heat
Assisted
Magnetic Recording
Die Festplatte wird
irgendwie auf, also so
ich habe es mir so ganz
grob angeguckt, ja.
Ich meine Terabyte, ja.
Nicht Gigabyte, Terabyte. Ne, ne.
Also, die Festplatte wird
erhitzt auf irgendwie 450 Grad.
Es kann auch mit
Lasern sein, ich weiß nicht. Zumindest
an den Stellen, wo geschrieben wird. Die Festplatte wird
erhitzt auf 450 Grad
und dadurch
braucht man wohl
weniger Energie
für das Magnetfeld.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung und zumindest
unterm Strich führt das dazu,
dass der Schreiblesekopf kleiner werden
kann und dementsprechend mehr Bits
auf die Scheibe
lassen.
Aber das ist glaube ich noch ziemlich
ja so
ne, experimentell kann man nicht sagen.
Fahrenheit oder
Celsius macht bei 450 Grad
doch auch kaum einen Unterschied noch.
Das macht es auch noch mehr fett, ob es Fahrenheit
oder Celsius sind bei 450.
Ähm
Also das ist nicht wirklich experimentell.
Die
liefern das ja schon aus.
Aber das ist auch nicht so unbedingt
serienreif ready für Consumer
Produkte.
Aber es ist coole Technik, ja.
Lass uns doch mal angucken,
wie das funktioniert.
Wikipedia, der findet bestimmt Hammer
jetzt. Ne, guck mal, Wikipedia.
Gibt's das auch
auf deutsch.de?
Hey.
Heat Assisted Magnetic Recording.
Zu deutsch
Wärme unterstützte Magnetaufzeichnung.
Ah, yes, exzellent.
Die Domäne.
Der Weißbezirk,
was?
Klingt ja fast schon ein bisschen nach
Racism, alter. Der Weißbezirk.
Achso, das heißt
so, weil der Typ das erfunden hat.
Ah, er war das, okay.
Ach, das ist quasi die Einheiten
auf dem Plan. Doch, das könnte
durchaus mit Laser funktionieren. Könnte ich
mir tatsächlich vorstellen. Ähm
Also, welche
Daten geschrieben sind? Zunächst lokal
durch einen Laser über die
Curie-Temperatur erhitzt.
Um das für eine,
für einen Schreibvorgang nötige
Magnetfeld möglichst klein zu halten.
Und das Schreiben trotz schwach
ausgeprägten
Superpra...
Superparamagnetischen
Effekts zu ermöglichen.
Jetzt ist alles obviously klar, oder?
Zumindest passt mehr auf die Platte
drauf, unterm Strich. Das ist das, worauf's
ankommt.
Ja.
Und damit gibt's jetzt 30 Gigabyte
Festplatten. Was echt
witzig ist, und mal richtig
großer Sprung,
weil die letzten Jahre über hat sich
zwar bei Platten auch ein bisschen was getan,
aber es war lange Zeit so im Bereich,
sagen wir mal, 14, 16,
18 Terabyte
und jetzt der Sprung auf 30
ist schon extrem
pogu. Und das findet ihr nicht.
Allerdings sind die Dinger saumäßig
teuer noch. Geh ich mal ganz stark
von aus. Ähm...
Die Performance
sackt halt auch ein bisschen.
Das ist glaube ich auch irgendwo drinnen.
Also was heißt die Performance sackt?
Das ist jetzt keine Platte, die
neue Geschwindigkeitsrekorde aufstellt.
Und...
Ich glaube es ist einfach
auch noch ein bisschen teuer für den normalen Anwender.
Auf der anderen
Seite, performancetechnisch
ist gar kein allzu großes Problem.
Warum hab ich's denn
immer mit Gigabyte? Ich mein Terabyte.
Ähm...
Also performancetechnisch
ist glaube ich gar nicht so schlimm.
Weil im Ernst, wenn man eine NAS betreibt
oder ein bisschen, ich sag mal ein bisschen
höherpreisigere Storage,
dann hast du da eh irgendwelche
SSDs drinnen als
Cache und
dann macht's eigentlich
das nicht großartig
aus. Ob die Platte jetzt mit
80, 100,
150, 200, was auch immer
MB die Sekunde schreibt.
Ich mein schneller ist natürlich immer besser.
Aber 2TB SSD sind günstig.
Zumindest als Cache sollte man sich einen reinhauen.
Und insofern...
Naja, ich hab auch keine Festplatten
mehr bei mir.
Das stimmt glaube ich gar nicht. Lass mal kurz gucken.
Doch, ich hab noch
eine 13 oder eine 14TB ist das glaube ich.
14TB Magnetfestplatte
drin. Ansonsten hab ich
1, 2,
3,
4 SSDs drin.
Richtig, mein Android Server hat
auch noch Magnetfestplatten drin.
Und ich glaube für
sowas ist das gar nicht schlecht.
30TB Platten, wenn die denn mal irgendwie
halbwegs erschwinglich sind. Weil da ist die
Performance ja nicht so wild.
Wenn man eine SSD
oder vielleicht sogar 2 SSDs
hat,
die
das Cachen können alles, dann ist
das nicht wild.
Also ich glaube
früher oder später wird das auch
bei Home
NAS Betreibern oder
bei Reddit Data
Hoarder ist das bestimmt so eingekommen.
Ja die BX500 suckt, deswegen ist da auch nichts drauf.
Aber die hatte ich noch übrig.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, hey so eine SSD
für Videoaufzeichnungen zum Beispiel.
Weil die macht ja
nicht viel, die macht 200 MB die Sekunde oder so.
Für Videos reicht das. Ist ganz praktisch.
Weil die Zugriffszeiten sind ganz gut und
ja mal gucken. Ich weiß nicht was ich da
drauf mache.
Also aktuell hab ich es tatsächlich
eher so, dass
ich hier ein bisschen Gaming Zeug
drauf habe.
Da fehlt noch eine. Leute da fehlt
noch eine.
Da fehlt noch eine.
Es sind
weird Flags, aber
es sind eigentlich 5
SSDs, weil
das
Laufwerk wo ich mein Shadowplay
Recording drauf mache ist nicht da.
Das mach ich nicht hier drauf.
Tja gut.
Ich glaube ich weiß woran
es liegt. Ja logisch.
Ich anmaunte die, wenn ich mich abmelde
von meinem normalen Windows
Account. Warum alles lokal
und kein NAS dafür? Warum nicht lokal und
NAS? Naja Games und solche Sachen
und Videorecording willst du schon auf irgendeine
lokale SSD machen.
Also ja, du kannst theoretisch natürlich
auch das auf ein NAS
machen. Allerdings da ist der 2TB
Cache jetzt auch nicht unbedingt das Beste.
Mal angenommen, ich komm wieder auf
die Idee und warum hab ich auch nicht Linux
Mint offen? Wollte ich jetzt gar nicht haben. Mal
angenommen, ich komm wirklich auf die Idee und nehme mal
einen armen Battlefield auf oder ein paar Tage
Battlefield auf. Also das
kann durchaus sein, dass das dann mit 2TB
irgendwie so an die Grenze kommt.
Relativ zackig nach einer Woche.
Also das ist nicht so gut. Am besten ist
Videos lokal aufnehmen und
die Runden die
gut sind aufs NAS schieben.
Funktioniert einfach besser.
Heute neue Distro probieren. Wir könnten
uns, wenn wir gerade dabei sind, was haltet
ihr denn davon, wenn wir uns mal wieder Linux
Mint angucken? Ich empfehle das immer.
Wir gucken mal ins Archiv, weil
wir das zuletzt gemacht haben.
Kann man das nach Datum? Oh, man kann das nach
Datum sortieren.
Und man kann sogar umstellen!
Alter!
Man kann sogar mittlerweile umstellen, dass man nur den Titel
durchsucht. Hyper Feature
Implementation hier beim Archiv.
Das ist ja
extremst
ist das.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Jay, Dankeschön für den Sub. Und sorry, falls ich
irgendjemanden übersehen habe vorhin.
Wir können uns heute tatsächlich Linux Mint.
Ich schreib das mal in den Titel rein. Komm, heute gucken wir uns
mal. Das krieg ich auch in
1,5 Stunden hin. So viel gibt's ja da
nicht anzugucken.
Weil ich empfehle das immer.
Lunux Mint. Genau. Lunux. Kennt ihr das
auch? Das ist ja der
Bruder von TempleOS. Lunux.
Wann kam das raus?
Release Date.
Linux
Mint Release Date.
Victoria will arrive im
Können wir schon ne Beta ausprobieren?
Wobei, April,
Mai, Juni.
Hm.
Okay, was haltet ihr davon, wenn wir uns
das heute angucken und im Juni, wenn's
rauskommt, dann nochmal, dass wir sehen, was sich
getan hat.
Ups, da wollt ihr nicht.
Was sich getan hat.
Vera ist aktuell angesagt.
Kam raus. Ach, guck mal.
Kam doch erst, kam doch erst vor
ein paar Monaten raus. Können wir uns tatsächlich angucken.
Ja, ja, ja, okay.
Ich ändere mal den
Titel. Brauchen wir irgendein
dummes, dummes
Emote dabei. Gibt es ein...
Gibt es nen... Alter, ist
das Pinguin Emote vielleicht
hässlich von Windows 11? Guckt euch das mal
an.
Also das hier, das hier ist gut.
Der Windows, der Windows 11er ist gut. Der Windows 10er
mein ich, ist hässlich.
Guckt euch mal der Windows...
Guckt euch mal das Windows 10
Pinguin Emoji an.
Ja, Moment.
Wir zeigen... haben die jetzt hier gar keine
Windows... Windows 11 ist halt mega hässlich.
Einfach nur.
So, machen wir einfach mal hier so als Titel.
Ja, dann probieren wir das heute mal aus.
Ich empfehle das immer wieder,
Linux Mint, aber ich habe es erstaunlich
selten selbst benutzt.
Schauen wir mal, ob sich die Empfehlung
lohnt.
Ey, wie komme ich auf 10?
Das ist doch uralt, von 2010.
Ja, genau, das brauchen wir jetzt.
Was ich bei Linux Mint noch nicht checke ist,
haben die nicht vor einer Weile
gesagt, sie wollen jetzt auf Debian
aufsetzen? Oder
bringe ich das durcheinander?
Oder wann das andere?
Achso, hier unten.
Debian Edition. Ja gut, macht
eigentlich nicht wirklich
Sinn, oder?
Wait, du siehst das 11er Emoji,
obwohl ich das 10er geschrieben habe?
Willst du mich veräppeln?
Du könntest es auch von Android
oder IOS ausschreiben und die Dinger würden
gleich aussehen bei mir.
Das ist doch Chebait, oder?
Chat, ich hätte nicht
von euch erwartet.
Ihr Chebaitet mich.
You've got Chebaited.
Doch ist es.
Das Emoji,
wenn du das...
Wie nennt man das
korrekt? Ich glaube
Code Point nennt sich das.
Ich glaube Code Point nennt sich das.
Wenn du das gleiche Zeichen schickst,
dann ist es
wichtig, was ich für ein System
habe, beziehungsweise eigentlich ist nicht mal mein System wichtig,
wichtig ist mein Font-Renderer
und den Emoji-Font, den ich benutze.
So, laden wir das doch.
Gucken wir nochmal.
Download Linux Mint
21.1
Install Instructions
Ready for Download
Choose the right edition
Moment, die haben doch unterschiedliche ISOs.
Ich dachte, das ist alles auf einer drauf.
Warum macht man mehrere?
Welche wollen wir denn?
Hä? Da war ich doch gerade.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen Standard.
Wir machen
Cinnamon und
Mate. Ist das Wayland-based?
Ich hoffe nicht, dass das Wayland-based ist.
Ist das Wayland-based?
Dann bin ich...
verpackt mit meiner
VM. Wobei
Wayland durchaus funktioniert, richtig konfiguriert,
aber nicht gut in der VM.
Ok, Download. Auf geht's.
Let's go.
Downloads als 2,5G.
Ich will das nicht verifilen, ich will das einfach
downloaden.
Germany.
Von der Hochschule Esslingen. Ja, genau da.
Da wollte ich das schon immer
downloaden.
Warum Linux Mint?
Ehrlich gesagt, spontane Idee vom Chat.
Ich empfehle das immer, aber
es ist schon 2 oder 3 Jahre her, wo ich
das das letzte Mal ausprobiert habe.
Die Wayland-Geschichte
wird immer unsympathischer
und abstruser.
Es ist halt wieder so ein typisches Linux-Problem, dass
die Leute sich da so gegenseitig zeigen.
VMware sagt, da haben wir nichts mit zu tun.
Wayland sagt, da haben wir doch nichts mit zu tun.
Open VM Tools Leute sagt, da haben wir doch
nichts mit zu tun.
Ist halt wieder richtig abfuck.
Das ist doch das typische Linux-Problem, was ich auch schon
letztens im Stream mal ausführlich angesprochen habe.
Distrowatch Mint.
Ja, okay.
Und jetzt?
Oh, Wayland.
Okay, kein Wayland, sehe ich das richtig?
Kein Wayland?
Kein Wayland, oder?
Minus, minus, minus heißt kein Wayland.
Excellent. Sehr gute, sehr gute Sache.
Die Main-Maschine bleibt auf Arch.
Garantiert bleibt die Main-Maschine auf Arch.
Ich bin bei mir auf der Arbeit
sogar in einer...
Wie nennen sie das?
User-Group oder sowas.
Im Prinzip ist es ein Teams-Channel.
Arch-Linux-User.
Gibt sogar einen eigenen
Channel für bei uns in Teams.
Sind nicht viele Leute
drin, aber
dass es einen gibt, ist ja das Entscheidende.
Du rewritest gerade
das Archive-Backend.
Wie kannst du das Archive-Backend rewriten,
wenn du mit dem Archive
ansonsten nicht sonderlich viel zu tun
hast? Oder wie?
Verstehe ich das jetzt nicht?
Oder einfach just for fun.
Du baust sowas nach.
Okay, legen wir mal kurz eine neue VM an.
Sowas wie Django, bloß für Rust.
Ich stelle es mir ehrlich gesagt
eklig vor, damit zu arbeiten.
Weil Rust, Rust
versteht mich nicht falsch. Ich sage es ja immer wieder.
Rust ist im Vergleich zu C++ tatsächlich
eine ganz nice Sprache.
Aber Rust ist nicht für
Entwickler-Produktivität
im eigentlichen Sinne ausgelegt.
Die Sprache ist auch sehr, sehr umfangreich
und komplex und hat ganz viele
unterschiedliche Konstrukte.
Sondern Rust
finde ich, ist sinnvoll.
Allerdings nur in Bereichen,
die
eigentlich in zwei, eigentlich in zwei Fällen.
Ja, in Bereichen, wo
zusammenkommt, dass man Performance
braucht und es
nach Möglichkeit
Memory-Safe haben muss,
ohne in einer Managed-Plattform
oder auf einer
Managed-Runtime zu laufen.
Das ist der einzige Punkt, wo ich mir
denke, dass Rust wirklich sinnvoll ist.
Zum Beispiel ein Browser.
Ja, also
zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal Firefox.
Firefox ist ein
super Beispiel
für Rust.
Ich weiß, dass Firefox nicht
hier auf Rust in dem Sinne basiert, aber
Firefox, also ein Browser, ist ein gutes
Beispiel für eine Anwendung, wo sich Rust
lohnt. Das Ding braucht Performance
und
es muss Memory-Safe sein.
Also insofern ist
das wunderbar. Nicht
umsonst hat Mozilla Rust erfunden.
Ich glaube ursprünglich für ihre
CSS-Engine. Ansonsten
bin ich mir gar nicht mal so sicher,
welche
Teile im Firefox mittlerweile in Rust
sind und welche nicht.
Okay, ist ja auch sinnvoll.
Man will doch überall
ordentlich Performance und wenn möglich
Memory-Safety, oder nicht?
Ja, die Frage ist, willst du, sagen wir es mal, nennen wir es mal so,
möglichst kompromisslose
Performance mit
möglichst
guter Memory-Safety?
Oder reicht dir auch gute Performance
und Memory-Safety
und
Entwickler-Produktivität?
Das ist bei den meisten Projekten, würde ich
sagen, deutlich entscheidender.
Also kriegst du deine Anwendung in
zwei Monaten fertig oder brauchst du ein halbes Jahr für?
Oder ist die Performance jetzt nicht so
wild, ob das am Ende 100 Millisekunden
oder 150 Millisekunden braucht?
Man darf ja nicht vergessen,
so Java ist ja zum Beispiel,
ich nehme jetzt mal Java als Beispiel
oder Go
oder so, aber nehmen wir mal Java,
weil Java ist im Business-Umfeld halt sehr beliebt.
Java ist ja nicht langsam oder so.
Java ist, wenn man sich mal so Benchmarks
und Sachen anguckt, ist Java wirklich
ziemlich schnell.
Viele Anwendungen in Java sind scheiße, ja.
Aber Java selbst oder C-Sharp
auch. .net
ist also C-Sharp, also auf .net.
Das ist alles ziemlich schnell.
Und selbst JavaScript, wo sich immer so
drüber lustig kümmert, selbst JavaScript
ist verdammt schnell mittlerweile.
Wenn man nicht in irgendwelche doofen
Optimierungs-Edge-Cases reinläuft.
Auch sogar blödes PHP
ist nicht ganz so, aber auch
relativ schnell.
Habe ich den Download nicht gestartet?
Ist doch schon fertig.
Ist .net sowas wie die Java-VM?
Ja, genau.
.net ist die Runtime,
ist das JVM-Gegengestück von Microsoft.
Also die Dinger sind relativ schnell.
Was langsam as fuck ist,
sind so Sachen, also was wirklich langsam
as fuck ist, sind so Sachen wie Python
und Ruby. Allerdings Python
ist bisschen
außen vor,
weil viele Sachen, die dort
eben Performance-Probleme
machen würden, sind gar nicht
in Python selbst programmiert, sondern
in irgendwelchen C und C++-Modulen.
Deswegen kann ja auch
dieses ganze Machine-Learning-Zeug
und AI-Zeug
so gut in Python gemacht
werden,
weil die den Kram eben in einer ordentlichen
Programmiersprache programmiert haben,
wo Performance wichtig ist.
Und dann aus einer
Programmiersprache ansprechen,
die sich gut programmieren lässt.
Ja, das tut es
nicht verkehrt. Mach ruhig deine Sachen in Rust,
ich will da gar nichts gegen sagen.
Aber Performance-Memory-Safety,
also kompromisslose Performance-Memory-
das ist nicht immer das einzige.
Managed-Umgebung, sag mal sowas wie .net,
von Java, die sind von Haus aus
memory-safe,
wenn man nicht unsafe verwendet.
Ist tatsächlich in dem Fall sogar
ein bisschen wie in Rust,
wenn man nicht unsafe verwendet.
Und performance-technisch reichen
die für alles normalerweise, was
man so machen will, wenn es nicht gerade
Microcontroller sind oder irgendwelche Sachen,
wo man halt weiß, okay, da kommt es richtig krass
auf Performance an, wie zum Beispiel
einen Browser oder sowas.
Ich kann mir nämlich zum Beispiel nicht vorstellen,
dass jemand
auf die Idee kommt, eine Javascript-Engine
für einen Browser in
sagen wir mal
PHP zu bauen.
Okay, das ergibt jetzt auch
architektur-technisch relativ wenig Sinn.
Ja.
In Ruby.
Dafür wird es
nicht passen.
Aber ansonsten ist das
meiste
auch nicht
zu viel langsam, aber halt in kritischen Anwendungsfällen
zu langsam.
Ja.
Genau das meine ich, genau das meine ich.
C++ ist so ein typisches Ding.
Das Dumme, wisst ihr was das richtig dumme ist?
Ich will jetzt nicht wieder mit C++-Rant
anfangen, ja. Wisst ihr was das richtig
dumme an C++ und
Performance ist?
C++ dürfte glaube ich aktuell
mit die schnellste Programmiersprache sein, die es gibt.
Ey, ihr wisst, ich bin kein C++-Fan.
Aber wenn es um Performance geht,
gibt es eigentlich
nix, was so richtig an
C++ rankommt. Ja gut, du kannst deine Sachen
in C machen und wenn du weißt, was du in Rust
machst, ist das ähnlich.
Aber C++ ist eigentlich somit
das schnellste, was du aktuell benutzen
kannst. Aber das Dumme
an Performance in C++ ist,
dass alles so undurchsichtig
ist, ja.
Ich muss jetzt wirklich, eine Sache,
die haben ja seit ein paar
C++-Standards, haben die ihre
Move-Semantics.
Da kannst du zum Beispiel an
statt, dass du neuen Vektor
initialisierst, kannst du quasi
den Inhalt von der Liste
quasi als Grundlage für den neuen
Vektor nehmen, ohne dass du ihn quasi
die Werte, deine
Daten da rein kopieren musst. Ja, da kannst du quasi
deine Werte moven
in den Vektor. Wie auch immer,
Syntax
absolut, mal passt mal auf, Standard
Move Vector. Ich meine
alleine schon, alleine wenn ich
boah, Alter, mein Auge.
Ich meine, alleine
wenn ich schon diesen Mist hier lese, ja.
Ja, Qt ist tatsächlich ganz gut.
Allein schon, wenn ich sowas lese.
Also, so. Und
Es geht schon gut
los, man. Es geht schon gut los,
wenn ich sowas hier sehe, Alter.
Das ist so eine
Schrott-Sprache, man.
Obviously.
Das geht ja noch und das geht ja noch.
Leute, das ist ja noch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, das kann man aber verstehen.
Ah, okay.
Und, und
da kommen immer so diese Dinger so mit, ja,
und sonst was. Ja, also
wie gesagt, ich weiß, aber
es ist dann teilweise,
wie soll ich sagen,
der Typ muss es irgendwie
und der Typ muss es dann irgendwie
implizit unterstützen, dass du Elemente
da reinmoven kannst und man weiß
nicht so richtig, wann das wieder
Fall ist.
Und es ist so überhaupt
nicht, überhaupt nicht richtig
greifbar. Das ist quasi
Move-Semantics von Rust,
nur in schlecht.
In Rust ist das
richtig gut gemacht.
Das ist, würde ich sagen, eines mit der besten Sachen
in Rust. Weil Rust das
eben trackt, wo du wie was
movest und das lässt sich das
einfach nicht compilen, ja.
Und nachdem das Rust
es gar nicht compilen lässt,
kann sich Rust halt auch drauf verlassen,
dass es dann eben im Endeffekt auch
halt nur so ausgeführt
wird, wie es ausgeführt werden soll
und braucht keinen kryptischen Shit.
Ja, es wird noch
schlimmer. Ja, sie haben
ganz, ganz merkwürdige Sachen.
Es ist, ja, das ist
das Problem, weil in C++
es so wahnsinnig undurchsichtig
wieder gebaut ist. Und manche Typen
unterstützen es, manche Typen unterstützen es nicht
und dann guckst du auf Stack Overflow
und da kommt dann irgend so ein C++ Typ und sagt,
ah, obviously,
du benutzt ja auch einen
Standort,
einen Standard, frag mich nicht,
HashMap
Unsorted Reverse
Map Tree Lookup
Chrono
Time, was auch immer, so wie
die Dinger da auch heißen. Und dann sagen die, ja,
obviously, natürlich funktioniert
das damit nicht.
Und dann denkst du dir aber, warum? Warum funktioniert das mit dem Standard Vector
und mit dem Ding? Man versteht's nicht, Leute.
Versucht's auch gar nicht zu verstehen.
Ja, ist so.
Ja, ist einfach so.
Ja, stimmt, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich hab's mir noch nicht
angeguckt, was der neue C++ Standard
hergibt in der Richtung. Ich gehe
aber ganz stark davon aus, dass es
wieder nicht einheitlich ist, dass es
wieder was weiteres Neues ist,
was nicht in allen Fällen
gleich funktioniert,
beziehungsweise in manchen Fällen
fehlschlägt mit kryptischen Compilermeldungen
und du weißt nicht warum.
Mein Lieblings, mein Lieblings
C++... Moment.
Natürlich ist es nicht einheitlich,
was sonst? Es war ja, war ja klar.
Ähm, Leute,
ich hab, ich hab noch ein schönes
Ich hab noch ein schönes Beispiel
aus, das hab ich mir
extra rauskopiert aus einem meiner
Microcontrollerprojekte.
Ich bin mal,
ich bin mal gespannt, wer mir von euch sagen
kann, und dafür gibt's
tatsächlich eine, der erste, der mir
es erklären kann, was es macht,
weil ich hab's wieder vergessen, was es
macht. Der erste, der mir
erklären kann, was es macht, schlüssig
bekommt nen Prime Sub.
Ja, Challenge,
Leute. Let's go.
Anyone?
Irgendjemand?
Möchte mir jemand erklären,
was es macht?
Okay, wir fragen ChatGPT.
Das ist, das ist ne super Idee.
Ähm, Sekunde, Sekunde, ich muss, muss ich
kurz, kurz ausblenden.
Ich muss mich ja wieder einloggen.
Open AI,
verify you are human.
Ja, bin ich, bin ich. Login.
Moment, Moment.
Open, Open AI
Chat, Sekunde.
Gleich haben wir's.
Login. Auf ChatGPT
mach hin.
So, next, next,
next, dann,
okay.
Muss mal kurz heiden, meine letzten
Suchanfragen. Also, wir fragen mal, wir fragen mal
ChatGPT, was es macht.
Letzte Chance an euch, wer kann's erklären?
Wollen wir ChatGPT fragen?
SilverCross, danke für den
Sub.
Also default, lokal,
ja, das steht da. Das steht
da, aber was es macht, was
gibt das aktuelle
tausender Trendzeichen zurück? Ja, weiß
ich nicht. Ich frag euch ja, wenn ich's wüsste,
würd ich euch nicht fragen. Okay.
Also, wir fragen mal
ChatGPT.
Was macht
dieser C++
Code? Okay.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Dieser C++ Code ruft
die tausender Trendzeichen Eigenschaft aus
der Standard-Lokalisierung C ab.
Das tausender Trendzeichen
ist das Zeichen, das in einer numerischen Darstellung
Seriously, das
tausender Trendzeichen wird verwendet, um tausender
zu trennen. Name no shit.
Die Standard-Lokal erzeugt
ein Lokalobjekt, das die Spracheinstellung enthält.
Der Parameter
C gibt die Standard-Lokalisierung C lokal an.
Die Funktion standard use
facet
ruft danach
dann das facet Objekt
standard num. Ja, die Erklärung bringt
mir jetzt auch nichts. Standard num.
ab, dass das tausender Trendzeichen
enthält. Das Template-Argument
wchat
gibt den Typ des Trendzeichens an,
welches hier als white character
breites Zeichen
verwendet wird. Schließlich wird
die Funktion tausendselb aufgenommen, um das tausender Trendzeichen
aus der Standard-Lokalisierung C zu halten.
Ja,
alles klar, oder?
Habt ihr's verstanden?
Also, Leute, ich hab,
ich weiß wirklich
nicht mehr, woher ich das,
für was ich das benutzt hab. Ich gehe
davon aus, dass es
irgendwas war, für
Textformatierung
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Das hast du auch irgendwo rauskopiert,
oder? Also, ich weiß wirklich nicht
mehr, wofür, wofür ich das
verwende, aber ich hab das aus einem realen
Projekt, aber ich weiß, weil das soll schon wieder
use-facet sein und sowas.
Meine Güte, warum ist das so kompliziert?
Das war,
ich krieg es nicht mal zusammen, wofür
das war.
Aber ich mein schon leider, dass man zehn Minuten überlegen
muss, was das macht, ist doch schon wieder hängen geblieben.
Also, Standard-Lokal,
Standard-Lokal, so.
C ist
ja Default-Lokal,
okay. Ich, okay,
ich will, ich möchte raus
finden, welches
Zeichen, ich will raus
kriegen, welches das
Tausender-Trennzeichen
Zeichen ist, für meine
Standard-Sprache
nenn ich's mal, oder? Das hier ist
das, das hier ist für meine Standard-Sprache
die, das
Tausender-Trennzeichen, also sowas wie
ein Komma oder ein Punkt
und aus, ne, hä?
Ich versteh's, ich versteh's einfach nicht.
Beste Beispiel für Shit C++.
Kram, man.
Nie, niemand, niemand versteht's.
Ja.
Tatsächlich ein gekifteter Tange.
Hat er's, hat er's
zuerst gewusst, ja? Also, wie
gesagt, ich, ich, ich weiß nicht mehr, in welchem
Kontext das war, ich vermute mal, bei
irgendwelchem Text, Texts,
Textlogging
oder so. Ich hab
extra, also, wir, wir, wir lassen
das jetzt, wir, wir
lassen, wir lassen's jetzt gut sein mit C++-Rant.
Ähm.
Aber nur für den Fall der Fälle, dass
ihr mal ab und zu was hören wollt, ja?
Ich hab eine Textdatei bei mir
im Notiz, im Notizprogramm
die nennt sich
cpp-sucked
und die hat mittlerweile
Zeilen mit Beispielen
so in dieser Richtung.
Also,
ich hab da, ich hab da genug.
Mr. NSA
Dankeschön für den Sub, Pogu.
Für den Fiat schon der Quatsch dafür.
Hab ich nicht gebraucht. Okay.
Don't save. Gibt's da eigentlich
Okay, zu machen. Gibt's
da eigentlich Tickets oder
sowas? Oh, hier hab ich schon lange nicht mehr reingeguckt.
Was gibt's hier? Oh, hier gibt's, hier gibt's
neue Tickets. Tickets.
Postcommands
failing. Oh, echt?
Ha.
Ah, gut.
Hab jetzt kein Dock drauf.
Und hier gibt's nix Neues. Okay, gut.
Kurze GitHub-Projekte gecheckt. Also,
legen wir mal für Mint ne neue FVM an.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Custom. Next.
Next.
Ja.
4 CPUs. Cores. Ne.
1 CPU. Ja, nicht 41.
Ich mein, 1 und 4 Kerne, das muss reichen.
8G RAM sollte zum
Testen auch reichen. NAT ist auch
gut. Jawoll. Jawoll.
Jawoll.
Single-Disk. 80G
sollte zum Testen reichen.
Mint.
Hardware editieren. Printer weg.
Und
USB
weg. Und Soundkarte
weg.
Okay, let's go.
Auf geht's.
Ey, hab ich das
nicht im Mint genannt?
Hallo? Please.
Ich möchte renamen.
So, CD einlegen.
Downloads.
Mint Cinnamon.
Kein 4M Champ.
Naja, für grafische Ausgaben ist der 4M Champ.
Ich hab finished installing.
Für grafische Sachen ist der 4M Champ ja nix.
Dafür ist er nicht da.
Interessant.
Interessant. Guckte mal.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass mittlerweile
das Crab-Menü selbst
in 16 zu 9 ist.
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied
zwischen 4M Workstation und 4M Player?
4M Workstation
hat ein paar mehr Features.
Ich glaube zum Beispiel Snapshots.
Ich glaube Player hat keine Snapshots.
Und Snapshots sind eines der coolsten Sachen.
Ne.
Da rage ich bloß ab und zu
alle paar Streams mal ein bisschen draus rum.
Proxmox ist überhaupt keine Alternative dazu.
Proxmox ist eine
Virtualisierungslösung in Richtung
ESX, also
auf einer eigenen dedizierten Kiste.
Wenn du auf dem Desktop was virtualisieren willst, ist Proxmox nix.
Und gerade für grafische Ausgaben
ist Proxmox auch nix.
Wenn du es auf dem Desktop virtualisieren willst,
also insofern
ist das eine und das andere wirklich
nicht großartig Konkurrenz.
So, dann wollen wir doch mal.
Proxmox auf 4M installieren.
Das haben wir tatsächlich
sogar schon gemacht im Stream.
Das funktioniert auch zum ausprobieren, aber
ja, also
sinnig ist es natürlich nicht.
Kann es sein, dass
es hängt?
Kann es sein, dass es gar nicht richtig startet?
Oh Leute, ich muss EFI
booten.
Ne, es startet.
Wir können das Ganze schon mal ignorieren.
Ich muss das auf EFI boot umstellen,
weil wir wollen das Ganze ja schon unter halbwegs aktuellen
Bedingungen testen.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Das bootet im EFI Mode auch gleich viel schneller.
Schöner Mauszeiger.
Der Mauszeiger gefällt mir.
Ich glaube,
ohne Mist,
ich glaube den Mauszeiger hole ich mir
für meinen Arch
auch. Hier habe ich so
einen
Der ist jetzt nicht
mega hässlich oder so der Mauszeiger,
aber ja, also
ein bisschen größer wäre schon ganz gut.
Gibt es das extra?
Captain Frank?
Ne.
Was habe ich denn aktuell für Cursor?
Ich habe
aktuell Cursor
Kapitania. Ich habe Fake Mac Cursors.
Okay.
Ich bin auch hier.
Auch einer von euch, Leute.
Ich habe auch Fake
Apple Cursors.
Aber ich dachte mir,
vielleicht gibt es
den Mint Cursor hier auch.
Mint
Maus Cursor.
Wobei wir installieren das einfach mal
und gucken. Wir können ja nachgucken, was es für einer ist.
Lass mal kurz schauen.
Wie guckt man denn hier nach?
Preferences wahrscheinlich.
Achso, wir sind ja noch im
Live-System. Ne, ne.
Ich installiere erst mal.
So, Install.
Ubuntu. Das ist übrigens das einzig nennenswerte
neue bei 3304.
Es kam ja quasi vorgestern
das neue Ubuntu raus.
Ich glaube, das einzig wirklich sinnvolle
Ich mag den Mint Mauszeiger.
Der gefällt mir echt gut.
Ist der neue Installer.
Wie heißt der?
Bibata Modern?
Wie?
Bibata?
Material Based.
Bibata Modern.
Modern Classic.
Schick. Oh ne, ist das Gnome Only?
Ne, oder?
Der gefällt mir wirklich gut,
der Cursor.
Welchen braucht man jetzt
davon?
203.
Ja, okay. Bibata Cursor.
Bibata Cursor Theme.
Bin Translucent
Rainbow.
Ja, das untere ist es wahrscheinlich.
Sync Dependency?
Icon Click Gen?
Das ist nur zum Builden, oder?
Remove Make Dependency
After Install. Yes.
Probier jetzt mal kurz aus.
Yes.
Und jetzt please den ganzen Shit wieder deinstallieren,
den er da als Abhängigkeit installiert hat.
Ja, aber Downloads, Leute,
Downloads Sachen sind überhaupt kein Problem.
Was?
Was ist er doing gerade?
Lasst uns mal in Chat schauen.
Hat hier heute noch jemand die FISI
Abschlussprüfung geschrieben? Ja, Leute, erzählt!
Erzählt! Habt ihr FISI Abschlussprüfung
geschrieben heute? Wer hat, wer hat heute,
schreibt mal in Chat, wer hat heute FISI Abschlussprüfung
geschrieben?
Das interessiert mich.
Oder, oder, oder, oder AE Abschlussprüfung,
also muss ich FISI sein?
AE Abschlussprüfung.
Wer hat heute alles FISI
oder Fachinformatik Anwendungs an?
Oder FIAE
Abschlussprüfung geschrieben?
Erzählt mal, was kam denn
dran? Was haben, was wollen, erzählt
mal ein bisschen, das interessiert mich wirklich jetzt.
FISI 2023
News
Abschlussprüfung
War das heute?
26.4?
USV
Ja, Fragen zu USV kommen immer.
Ja, erzählt mal, was war denn so?
Ja, bei mir ist das auch schon eine Weile her.
Also, USV kam anscheinend dran.
STP, wirklich?
Die haben ernsthaft Spanning Tree Zeug abgefragt?
An die SFP vs. SFP Plus?
Oder STP?
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Oder meinst du beides?
SFP vs. SFP Plus,
RAID, DNS, IP,
USV, IP?
Beides.
Link Aggregation,
SCP.
Okay, da wollten sie es aber wirklich wissen.
Was habt ihr gestrichen?
Welchen Aufgabenteil habt ihr gestrichen?
Dann sage ich euch auch, was ich gestrichen habe.
Ich habe, glaube ich,
den einfachsten Teil gestrichen.
Das gibt es nicht mehr?
Achso. Ach, das mit Streichen gibt es nicht
mehr? Okay. Also, ich kann euch
aber sagen, was ich gestrichen habe.
Ich war einer der wenigen, der die
Programmieraufgabe gemacht hat in der Prüfung
und strukturierte Verkabelung
gestrichen hat. Weil ich habe
durchgeguckt, was machst du? Und am Ende
habe ich alles gemacht gehabt, bis
auf strukturierte Verkabelung.
Da habe ich einfach strukturierte Verkabelung.
Das ist wirklich mit Abstand der einfachste Step eigentlich.
Habe ich gestrichen.
Und wahrscheinlich war ich einer der
wenigen, der freiwillig die Programmieraufgabe
gemacht hat.
Allgemeiner Teil, Klassiker mit
Strukturkram und Pseudocode.
USV war aber scheiße. Die haben nicht nach
Rechnung gefragt, sondern nach den
Unterschieden zwischen
USV? Was hat denn USV?
Zwischen V
F I V I V F D
Ich weiß nicht mal,
was das sein soll. Virtual?
Virtual irgendwas? Das hat was mit
USV. Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich hätte
wirklich absolut keinen Plan gehabt.
Das sind irgendwelche
Frequenzsachen oder so.
Also, das hätte ich wirklich
auch nicht gewusst.
SFP, SFP Plus hätte ich was zu sagen
können, ja.
Im Netzwerkteil gab es keine einzige Aufgabe.
Subnetting oder Firewall, was soll das?
Ja gut, Subnetting ist eh overrated, outdated,
cheap-aided. Einfach
IP-Calc verwenden und fertig.
Ich glaube, die meisten freuen sich
sogar, wenn dieser Mist nicht in der Prüfung
drankommt. Aber Firewall-Regeln
sollten tatsächlich drin sein. Ich finde,
so ein bisschen, dass man
verstanden hat, so Firewall-Regeln,
die machen dann nicht mal
große Tests, ob es stateful oder
nicht stateful ist, das sollte
da schon rein. Ob da Subnetting
drin ist oder nicht.
Also, auf Subnetting könnte ich da verzichten, aber
Firewall-Sachen, so ein paar Basics, sollten schon
gefragt werden, finde ich.
Es gab auch eine Programmieraufgabe.
Kleines Programm erstellen sollte aus
einem Array mit Zahlen erkennen,
ob mehr als 18 Einträge
über 80% liegen.
Äh, 80%
von was?
80% von was?
Quatsch doch nicht, CPU-Last, oder?
Achso, die Zahlen gingen von 0
bis 100 oder was? Du sollst gucken, ob
mehr als 18 Einträge über 80
sind.
Achso, ja, das ist easy.
Ah, das ist wirklich...
Das hätte ich auch wieder gemacht und
irgendwas anderes gestrichen. Wobei, ja, wie gesagt,
man darf ja nix mehr streichen. Also,
ich weiß nicht, bis heute
nicht, was ich für ne...
was ich für ne Note...
Also, das hätte ich bestimmt nicht mehr nachgucken können,
hab ich aber nicht gemacht. Hat der jetzt noch
mehr Shit hier installiert?
War?
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Ähm, was wollt ich jetzt sagen?
Also, ich weiß nicht, was ich
in der Abschlussprüfung für ne Note hab.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Also,
vielleicht...
Vielleicht stand das irgendwo, ich weiß es
aber nicht. Ich glaube, es war keine...
Also, ich glaube, es war jetzt nicht super, super gut.
Dafür hab ich in der mündlichen Prüfung
95%, das weiß ich.
Insgesamtnote weiß ich auch nicht.
Hab ich mir
auch nie ausstellen lassen, den Zettel.
Okay. So, jetzt haben wir
einen neuen Cursor.
Nicht, dass uns das jetzt... Wollte ich jetzt
mal kurz ausprobieren. So, Cursor, Cursor,
hier. Biba Modern Classic.
Alter, mir gef...
Mir gefällt das richtig gut.
Mir gefällt der Cursor richtig
gut. Nehmen wir das in weiß oder
nehmen wir das in schwarz?
Ich nehm das mal in weiß, dass man
ein bisschen was erkennt.
Ja, in schwarz, okay.
Apply, so.
Und dann
gehen wir in mein XInit rein.
Hab ich die Cursor-Größe
hier irgendwo? Ich hab
keine Cursor-Größe, oder?
Ach doch. Cursor
size 24. Alles klar.
Okay, starten wir mal kurz das Ding.
Und...
Guck. Das ist doch
kein anderer Cursor jetzt, oder?
Hä?
Hä? Wait.
Hab ich nicht geplayt?
Hä? Hä?
Hä?
Wie jetzt?
Wie, wie jetzt?
Ja, wie?
Okay, das kann ich applyen, oder?
Kann ich das applyen?
What?
Ich kann die Maus-Cursor nicht applyen, Leute.
Was ist das denn?
Okay, dann werd ich das jetzt erst mal...
Nee, nee, nee. Sudo brauchen wir dafür nicht.
Ich werd das erst mal wieder aninstallen. Wir gucken uns
erst mal Mint an, weil sonst wird das heute nichts mehr.
Ich mein, ich hab sie nicht immer installiert.
Ich brauch so 45 Minuten Zeit.
Okay.
Install auf
Englisch. Ja, aber bitte die Tastatur
auf Deutsch. Ich hoffe, das erlauben die.
Ja.
German.
No dead key, please.
No dead key.
Beste, beste... Nee, einfach nur German, Leute.
German, no dead key.
One thumbnail.
Nee, Thumbnail. Fast.
Wo genau ist der Unterschied?
Der Unterschied ist, dass du solche Zeichen
machen kannst.
Dass du nicht
doppelt drücken musst und solche Dinger.
Sowas hier, zum Beispiel.
Also das...
Dead keys sind komplett useless. Shit.
Welche Distro ist das und welches
Terminal?
Das ist...
By the way, muss man das natürlich erwähnen.
Arch Linux.
Kombination
aus
Westterm als Terminal.
Arch Linux als OS.
Diese Icons
und Theme.
I3 als Window Manager.
Auflösung, ZSH
und...
Ja, von der ZSH-Config sieht man nicht so viel.
Also, wenn es dich genau interessiert,
gehst du einfach
auf GitHub.
Woblors.files
Und dann
guckst du zum Beispiel hier
in die
von meinem Prompt an.
Kannst dir alles angucken.
Was ist das?
Ach, das ist nicht mein Projekt. Das ist der Cursor.
Tmax oder Screen?
Weder noch
ein ordentliches Terminal.
Tmax ist eine super Geschichte auf dem Server.
Auf dem Desktop will ich es mittlerweile nicht mehr haben.
Ich habe ein Terminal, also in dem Fall
ist es Westterm.
Ich habe ein Terminal, das kann splitten.
Das kann... Ups, jetzt habe ich verdrückt.
Das kann horizontal-vertikal splitten.
Das kann zoomen.
Also Fullscreen machen.
Das kann hier Panels switchen.
Sogar übrigens mit Maus und Tastatur ordentlich.
Also mit Maus und
mit Tastatur ordentlich.
Man hat...
Ne, diagonal splitten kannst du nicht.
Du kannst mit der Maus auch die Dinger
verschieben, wenn du willst.
Ansonsten, was benutzt man in Tmax normalerweise
sonst noch häufiger?
Ja, du kannst
neue Sessions starten.
Ansonsten...
Ähm...
Was benutzt man in Tmax sonst noch häufiger?
Ich glaube, das sind so die Standardsachen.
Äh, Serious Max, ja das geht nicht,
wobei ich glaube gelesen zu haben,
dass es mittlerweile auch irgendeinen
Demon Mode oder sowas gibt.
Ja.
Und das hat den Vorteil, wenn man das hier im Terminal hat,
man kann Tmax auf dem Server starten
und muss dann nicht doppelt escapen.
So.
Install Multimedia Codex, ja mach mal.
Ups, jetzt habe ich Back gedrückt.
Leute, ich habe
den Installer geprickt.
Durch einen einfachen Klick auf Back,
so wie es ausschaut.
Ne, doch nicht.
Braucht bloß ewig.
Tmax ist sehr nice, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, du kannst alles, was du normalerweise
in Tmax alltäglich benutzt,
auch mit einem Terminal machen,
wenn das eben
die passenden Funktionen unterstützt.
Und dann hast du nicht das Problem,
wenn du auf dem Server bist,
dass du teilweise die Farben rumbacken,
deine Escape-Sequenzen rumbacken
und du doppelt escapen musst,
wenn du im Server was machen willst.
Also ich finde es viel, viel angenehmer,
lokal einen Terminal zu haben,
was Sachen wie Splits und sowas machen kann
und dann Tmax auf dem Server starten.
Das ist die beste Kombination,
die ich mir vorstellen kann.
Okay, excellent.
Preparing Ubuntu,
Jubantu Drivers, erase.
Jawoll, alles erasen.
Continue.
Max...
Max Virtual Machine,
bester Name überhaupt.
Passwort, Leute, best practice Passwort.
Da habe ich meine Zweifel,
dass das fair ist.
Ich habe 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 genommen.
Also mein...
Zumindest mal anzeigen, Achtung,
dein Passwort ist mega abgrundtief schlecht.
Könnte das...
Könnte das schon, ja.
Fair ist eine...
Fair heißt ja eigentlich sowas wie
okay, ja.
Fuck, Alter.
Wat...
What the f...
Alter!
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Okay, ihr fragt euch
jetzt wahrscheinlich, was will er?
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
What the f... Was ist... Hä?
Ich zeige
euch mal was, Leute.
Sekunde.
Vorhin, als ich auf YouTube
in die Analytics geguckt habe von meinem
aktuellen Video, sah das noch ganz
normal aus.
Und...
Und seit, keine Ahnung,
zwei Stunden oder so,
ist das... macht das Video
mega stonks.
Guckt mal.
Hier habe ich geguckt vorhin.
Hier irgendwo habe ich geguckt vorhin.
Jetzt auf einmal...
Richtig big stonks.
Das Video habe ich in 30 Minuten
aufgenommen, zusammengeschnippelt
und abgeladen. Das ist so ein richtiges
Low-Effort-Video gewesen, aber
ich muss sagen, ich fand das Thema wirklich
spannend, aber ich bin auch total...
total spät dran.
Das Gameplay haben doch... Ich dachte, das haben
alle schon gesehen. Ich sage einfach mal
was zu, so mein Senf, weil ich habe
das selber heute Morgen zum ersten Mal gesehen.
Aber anscheinend kommt das gut an.
Hyper stonks.
Ich habe es heute Morgen zufällig
das erste Mal gesehen. Leute, man merkt,
wenn man spät dran ist, wenn sogar die
ARD darüber schon berichtet hat.
Die ARD hat da heute Morgen was zugesagt, Mann.
Hat mir mein...
Mein Social Media
Experte, Manager
erzählt,
dass sogar die ARD das heute Morgen
erzählt hat in irgendwie...
Auf irgendeiner Seite von ihnen, keine Ahnung.
Dann weißt du, du bist spät dran.
Schau mal, woher die Views kommen.
Das sieht man noch gar nicht
so richtig im Detail. Ich kann nur
nachgucken. Die Views
kommen von
YouTube Recommendations
auf YouTube
auf der
Startseite
und im
Subscription-Feed,
logischerweise,
und external.
External gibt es auch relativ viele
Aufrufe. Also, die Verteilung ist
wie folgt.
13.000 Views kommen von
der Startseite.
Vom Subscription-Feed
jetzt.
Und von extern kommen
2,5k.
Aber da sind auch viele
von Twitter
rübergekommen und sowas.
Ich muss das mal kurz vergleichen,
wie das zum Beispiel aussieht.
Das interessiert mich jetzt.
Mit meinem letzten Video
da ist external
so gut wie gar nichts.
Hat mich irgendeine
News-Seite oder so verlinkt?
Kann das sein?
Hat irgendeine News-Seite
mal ein Video verlinkt
oder sowas?
Weil es sind erstaunlich
viele aus external jetzt.
Ich mein, sind immerhin
irgendwie an die 10%
oder so der Viewer von external.
Okay, Moment.
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz
an Twitter.
Twitter kommt normalerweise
immer ein bisschen was rein, aber nicht 10%
der Viewer.
Sekunde, wir checken das jetzt einfach mal kurz.
Man sieht leider external
nicht von wo.
Suchen wir mal danach.
Mal einen Video-Titel.
Um ein Video, warum ein Video so abgeht
ging es gerade drum.
Und ansonsten haben wir gerade
LuxMint installiert.
Ich will mich mal nicht
beschweren.
Ist schon okay.
Darf ruhig Views geben.
Früher hat man gesehen, woher die external
Zuschauer kommen, aber ich glaube
dass
das sieht man mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Man sieht wirklich nur
external, man sieht nicht
man sieht nicht wo von
external.
Ich glaub das gibt es nicht mehr.
Das passt.
Irgendjemand hat mich verlinkt.
Ich weiß nicht wo, keine Ahnung.
Ich seh das.
Das Video
das ging steil.
Aber
eine Stunde später
kamen dann auch die ersten external Aufrufe
rein.
Leute versteht mal
irgendjemand was auf YouTube abgeht.
Das checkt eh niemand.
Egal.
External ist ja alles möglich.
Also wenn mich irgendeine News-Seite verlinkt hat
dann
man sieht es halt nicht mehr.
Warte mal.
Wir fragen mal.
Das interessiert mich jetzt echt.
YouTube Analytics
See which
external source.
How do I find external
traffic source? Moment.
Aha.
Siehste mal. Leute.
Ich mach seit
13 Jahren YouTube und ich hab keine Ahnung
von YouTube. Wo wir wieder aber am Thema sind.
Dass ich wahrscheinlich der
planloses YouTuber auf der Welt bin was das
angeht. Analytics.
Okay.
Reach.
External traffic
sources.
Google search. Über die
Google-Suche.
Die Leute suchen schlicht und ergreifen danach
und finden mein Video.
Über die fucking. Das hatte ich ja auch noch nie.
Dass 10% der Viewer
einfach random über die Google-Suche
kommen. Alter.
Über die Google-Suche.
Nice. Okay.
Soll mir recht sein.
Kein Ding. Alles gut.
Passt. Nice.
GG. Next.
Google-Suche darf mich ruhig weiter promoten.
Der Videotitel ist aber ganz catchy.
Leute falls ich irgendwelche Fragen
und Sachen von euch übersehen hab. Schreibts ruhig
nochmal in den Chat. Ich hab grad
die letzte Zeit nicht reingeguckt.
Oh es werden Leute gebannt. Hier gehts wieder zur Sache.
Haben die mittlerweile.
Hat Mint mittlerweile
Fiber-Tools installiert?
Ah.
Anscheinend nicht.
Das finde ich immer ein bisschen blöd.
Seriously. Ich könnte mir vorstellen.
Es ist doch kein großer
Akt oder?
Fiber-Tools
standardmäßig zu installieren. Also ich meine das könnten sie doch machen.
Up Install
Open
VM
Tools. Was ist der Unterschied
zwischen Desktop und
nur Tools?
Was?
Was macht es?
Ich weiß nicht. Wir.
Installieren sie einfach mal.
Oh. Zack. Fullscreen.
Nice. Da haben wir
Linux Mint am Start. Was haben wir denn hier?
Ein Linux Mint Cinnamon Edition.
Du benutzt Mint seit einem Jahr
und bist sehr zufrieden? Ja ich empfehle
Mint auch immer hier im Stream für
Einsteiger. Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass
es bei mir glaube ich selbst schon 2 oder 3 Jahre
her ist, wo ich mir das das letzte Mal angeguckt hab.
So also das wichtigste erstmal ist
dass ihr alles ein bisschen größer stellt. Ich meine
Boomer Augen, das geht doch nicht so.
An A minus A
es ist ein 515er
Kernel.
Ah ja. Geht doch.
Geht auch in Ordnung.
So also. Ist jetzt nicht
Steinzeit.
Dürfte. Ich weiß nicht wann vor 515
rausgekommen ist. Wahrscheinlich vor
3, 4
Monaten oder so.
Wann kam das raus? Steht das auch irgendwo dabei?
Ja 22. Ja ok.
Vor einem halben Jahr.
Also ist nicht mehr taufrisch.
Wobei das erscheint mir ein bisschen sehr alt
ehrlich gesagt.
Das erscheint mir ein bisschen sehr alt.
515 Linux
Der muss neuer sein eigentlich.
Wisst ihr wie blöd
Blogposts sind?
Ne das ist tatsächlich
fast schon ein halbes Jahr alter Kernel.
Da ist bestimmt neuer
Kernel dabei. Ja aber
kein Major Versions
Upgrade. Das passiert ja in der gleichen
Release nicht.
Sogar noch älter als ein halbes Jahr.
Upgrade mal.
Es gibt keinen
neuen Kernel dafür.
Das ist der neueste.
Steam soll ich? Warum soll ich Steam installieren?
Willst du einfach nur
wissen ob es funktioniert?
Können wir machen. Ich werde mich hier nicht einloggen
und spielen können wir in der VMA nix.
Also insofern. Wir können gucken
ob Steam dabei ist und starten.
Macht Mint
eigentlich auch diesen Müll von Snaps
wie Ubuntu? Das muss ich jetzt gleich mal
überprüfen. Lass mal kurz
in Chrome starten. Ist das Firefox?
Ist das ein Snap?
Nein. Es ist kein Snap. Ne.
Es ist kein Snap.
Es ist, es ist ein echter
ein echter Firefox.
Nicht
dieser Müll wie es Ubuntu macht.
Wollt ihr
mich verarschen?
Abbrechen. Next.
Wisst ihr schon jetzt gleich viel schneller. Easy.
Mint entfernt Snap und
baut Firefox und Chrome selbst. Ja sehr gute
Entscheidung. Ganze
Die Leute
bei Canonical die sind mehr damit beschäftigt
sich zu überlegen wie sie
das System mit weiterem Snap Müll
voll klatschen können. Anstatt
mal irgendwie zu überlegen
was man mal wieder innovatives machen
könnte. Mint Key Selling
Point ist ja das es kein Snap ist. Ja.
Ich weiß nicht ob das der Key Selling Point
ist. Was übrigens richtig
krass Business Stocks mäßig klingt.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall
für mich ein großer Pluspunkt
dass es kein Snap hat.
Restore Session. Ja aber wir haben keine
Recent History.
Ach Snap suckt.
Benutzen die wirklich
Mint? Ja gut kann ich mir vorstellen.
Aber
Snap
Das schlimme ist das sogar Snap
mittlerweile sagt bitte starten sie jetzt mal ihren
Firefox neu und wenn du es nicht neu
gestartet hast wir werden ihn dir unterm
Arsch wegziehen innerhalb der nächsten 10
Tage wenn du nicht rechtzeitig neu startest und sowas.
Also das ist eher was was man von
Windows kennt und nicht von
irgendeinem ordentlichen Linux. Ich meine ich starte den Kram
meistens eh nach Updates
öfters mal neu und lasse es keine 10 Tage
laufen aber trotzdem. Muss ja nicht sein.
So auf jetzt mach mal hin
Updater. Updater
Updater mal.
Bisschen zackiger.
Das mit Steam kann ich tatsächlich mal
ausprobieren. Was ist das hier? Oh.
Ich hätte nicht über CLI upgraden müssen
ich hätte auch einfach hier upgraden können.
Na gut.
Was Systems
Man kann Systems Snapshots damit
machen. Do you want to switch
to a local mirror?
Ja okay.
Ja wir hätten das gleich mal testen sollen
über das UI
was ja viele Leute machen.
Packages hier.
Dogadoo GmbH
Okay und Base
Images kommt hier von
Oh von denen ja ganz toll.
Okay.
Ist schon mal ganz gut. Das ist alles
geupdatet wird.
Über das UI und
wie gesagt. Ihr kennt mich. Ich bin kein großer
Fan von irgendwelchen UI updatern
und Sachen. Aber
ich glaube für den normalen User ist das
halt. Was ist denn jetzt los hier?
Die FH Aachen ist lahm oder?
Meine Internet Connection
ist in Ordnung. Soviel kann ich euch sagen.
Hostingeurope.de
Okay. Und das hier
gibt Dogadoo.
Was ist das?
Ronix.
Die Friedrich Alexander University
of Erlangen.
Ja auch gut.
Let's go.
Easy hat funktioniert.
Ja habe ich schon gemacht.
Nein das war alles gut.
Okay. Gut wir können hier
über das UI nichts updaten. Weil ich habe ja gerade
Ich mag das Cursor
Theme. Das gefällt mir wirklich gut.
Ich muss mal gucken wie ich das auch unter
meinem Manjaro. Nicht Manjaro. Unter meinem
Archie zum Laufen gehe. Das Cursor Theme.
Das gefällt mir. Das hat echt was.
So wir haben den Clip
Bot. Oh
ich hätte gedacht es wäre ein Clipboard Manager da unten.
Ne
jetzt ist er wieder weg. Gibt es
keinen Clipboard Manager?
Und wie macht
man hier Snapshots? Angeblich
kann das Snapshots machen. Ah hier ist es
zum Snapshots. Aha
aha. Also ja gut
wir haben nicht auf BTFS installiert.
Okay das
dann ist es quasi
ein R-Sync
Frontend. Aber nicht schlecht, dass
sowas direkt dabei ist. Ich meine warum nicht?
Ist doch eine coole Sache.
Ja gut das testen wir jetzt nicht. Brauchen wir nicht.
Ich habe nur VM. Da kann ich auch so Snapshots
machen. Okay wir starten mal neu.
Wenigstens
mal ein Menü wo man was drin findet.
Wir starten mal neu, dass er auch die neuesten Kernel
und die ganzen Updates lädt. Und dann gucken wir
wirklich ob man Steam über den Package Manager
installieren kann. Ob das auch startet.
Wie gesagt
ich kann mich jetzt nicht einloggen weil ich meine
Daten nicht da habe und was spielen in der VM geht
eh nicht. View Kernels
soll man machen.
Okay gibt es irgendein
First Step Documentation
Ach ja!
Ja das ist ja
schick. Das gefällt mir.
Ja das gefällt mir gut.
Hör mal das hier. Das gefällt mir tatsächlich
gut, dass du direkt gleich im
Was haben wir denn? Modern?
Traditional?
Modern. Ja.
Kann man schon ein bisschen größer machen. Mit Boomer Augen
ist kein Ding.
System Snapshots hatten wir schon. Driver
Manager. Gut.
Da gibt es für vor allem.
Das ist gut gemacht.
Ich bin ja immer sehr pingelig.
Aber das sieht wirklich sehr
so aus einem Guss aus.
Ist ganz gut, dass ich Mint empfehle wahrscheinlich.
Update Manager System
Settings. Launch.
Das ist easy. Das könnte meine Mutter auch
benutzen.
Sogar mein Vater würde das hinkriegen.
Dann würde er sich
wenigstens seinen Rechner nicht so voller Viren hauen.
Was er
hat wahrscheinlich keine Viren, aber
dann ist die Gefahr nicht so
groß. Leute ich war letztens bei
meinem Vater, weil sein Rechner
nicht ging. Ich habe mich breitschlagen
lassen und der Typ hat ernsthaft. Müsst
ihr euch mal vorstellen. Also ich hatte
eben da mal Windows
11 drauf installiert. Da ist ja Windows Defender
dabei. Der Typ hatte
drei zusätzliche Viren Scanner
installiert.
Überlegt euch das mal. Drei zusätzliche
in Windows 11.
Der hatte installiert Avira.
Ich kriege es nicht mehr zu. Das waren drei Stück.
Das erste hat sich gar nicht. Malware Bytes.
Malware Bytes.
Avira Malware Bytes.
Was gibt es denn
sonst noch bekanntes?
Bitdefender oder sowas
glaube ich. Ich glaube Bitdefender.
Avira Bitdefender
und Malware Bytes.
Alter was hast
du auf deinem Rechner gemacht?
Ja und Windows Defender.
Software Manager
können wir starten. Okay.
Und die Firewall können wir
starten. Nicht das man das jetzt wirklich brauchen
würde normalerweise.
Erlebniskiste. Ah das
ist UFW. Ja das ist
so ziemlich das hässlichste und
useleste Firewall UI
was mir so einfällt.
Aber ich finde das sehr schick
gemacht hier. Da findet sich auch jemand, also wirklich
jeder damit zurecht. Gar kein Ding.
Gut das ist das Standard Software Center.
Das kannst du eh.
Brauch ich nicht.
Moment. Moment. Gibt es
Wobbly Windows?
Gibt es die Möglichkeit Wobbly
Windows zu machen?
Das brauche ich Leute. Sekunde. Sekunde.
Das muss ich checken.
Wobbly Windows.
Extension. Jawoll.
Cinnamon Spices.
Oh was ist denn das?
Irgendein. Ist das irgendein
Argin Manager?
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Copy the Files?
Oh ne das ist ja abartig.
Das ist ja eklig gemacht.
Antivirus installieren.
Welche Files denn überhaupt? Download.
Ok.
Guck mal ob ich Zips extra
hier hin lasse. Wir machen das jetzt mal wie der letzte
Kack Noob hier über das UI.
Ich muss jetzt nach Punkt Local.
Da fängt es schon an. Wie lässt man sich
hier was. Schau hinten Files. Ok.
Das Local.
Ne wohin muss es hin?
Local Share
Cinnamon Extensions.
Und das muss da rein.
Einfach so?
Ja anscheinend.
Und jetzt?
Enable Extended Cinnamon
Setting plus Button.
In den Settings.
Hier bin ich.
Ne Cinnamon
Settings soll ich.
Extensions.
Da ist es.
Jetzt.
Wichtig.
Wie aktiviert man das jetzt? Enable.
Oh.
Jawoll.
Hast du Kack Javascript? Du meinst das ist Javascript?
Pod?
Aber endlich.
Ja so mag ich
das. Das gefällt mir.
Das ist kein PPGA Plugin.
Das ist so ziemlich das geilste was es eigentlich
früher gab unter Linux. Unter normalen
Window Managern.
Leider.
Leider gibt es Compets in der Form
und Weise irgendwie nicht mehr.
Das ist das einzige was
ich an i3 vermisse.
Weil i3 hat keine Fenster in dem Sinn.
Doch i3 hat Fenster.
Aber i3
und Compets
gehen halt nicht zusammen.
Das gefällt mir. Das muss ich behalten.
Cool wäre jetzt wenn
Moment.
Warte mal.
Man kann das direkt hier runter drunter.
Moment.
Man hätte es direkt hier von runter
laden können Leute.
Ich hätte überhaupt.
Ich hätte es überhaupt nicht kopieren müssen.
Das ist ja sogar noch besser als ich gedacht habe.
Ok lasst es mal.
Sekunde.
Wir disablen das mal wieder.
Die sammeln bei mir wirklich Pluspunkte gerade.
Finde ich sehr sehr nice.
Wir löschen
das mal wieder. Mal gucken ob das on the fly ist.
Ok da geht es los.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Hier wahrscheinlich.
Ok Extensions.
Wir löschen das mal wieder.
Also mal gucken. Jetzt sind die Extensions
weg. Ja hier. Was? No.
Ok. Yes.
Download.
Compets.
Compets. Ja.
Guck mal man kann es direkt hier runter.
Ja das ist ja nice. Das ist viel besser als
irgendwie so ein Shit den man
sich aus dem Internet runterladen muss.
Und jetzt? Kann man einfach sagen
Enable?
Ja. Ne.
Something went wrong.
Ich vermute mal weil ich es einmal
runtergeladen habe und einmal so.
Ich glaube
damit kommt dann nicht klar wenn es schon mal geladen war.
Runter war. Das ist das falsche?
Wirklich?
Ne das ist das richtige.
Hermes 83.
Das ist das was ich eben runtergeladen habe.
Compets Window Effect Hermes 83.
Das ist das richtige.
Finde ich gut gemacht.
Hier kann man Settings von einstellen.
Was ist mit dem da drüber? Keine Ahnung.
Aber wir müssen jetzt erstmal rebooten.
Weil das aller wichtigste ist
das Wobbly Windows funktioniert.
Ohne Wobbly Windows ist ja useless.
Dice Tries. Danke für den Sub.
Useless.
Pass auf jetzt geht es. Wobbly Windows.
Jawoll.
Endlich. Endlich.
Wobbly Windows.
Ok ich sehe mich da tatsächlich
das ab und zu mal zu verwenden
das System. Allein schon weil es Wobbly Windows hat.
Das ist das beste Feature ever.
Ich verstehe ja immer noch nicht
warum sie Compets in die Tonne gekloppt haben.
Und nicht einfach weiter
Compets weiter
entwickelt haben und
Mainstream mäßig verwenden unter Linux.
Aber das ist einfach das beste hier.
Was haben die denn sonst noch für Extensions?
Ich weiß das ist ja so wirklich Distro
nicht wirklich Distro testen aber
ok viele Sachen
sind es ja nicht.
Transparentize
your panel
no any
was?
Teil your windows as you like
desktop cube
desktop cube?
Aber das ist auch für den Oldschool Compets
Effekt natürlich sehr nice.
Compets cube.
Enable hotkey
Wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Ja stimmt wie switch ich
eigentlich desktops hier?
Ah haben wir das nächste. Wie switch ich
zwischen mehreren desktops?
Workspace Manager
Enable Workspace
Allow
Cycling through Workspaces
Yes. Ja ok
wunderbar aber
was hier vorne ist Workspace ist gar nichts oder?
Ja nö.
Unten rechts. Ne das ist eigentlich Desktop
Anzeigen. Vielleicht muss man
das auch explizit hier wieder rein machen
das kann ja schon sein.
Applets
Hier muss man das bestimmt
Ne Applets sind die
Dinger hier rechts oder nicht?
Workspace Switcher da ist es doch.
Ok jetzt haben wir einen Workspace Switcher
aber wie man den Würfel
wie man den Würfel aufmacht
weiß ich nicht. Aber das ist tatsächlich echt
nicht schlecht. Gefällt mir.
Gefällt mir wirklich ganz gut bis jetzt.
Hotkey. Tja ich würde
den Hotkey suchen wenn man den also
der Hotkey da stehen würde.
Steht er ja nicht. Man kann ihn in Settings
aber ja.
Vielleicht sollten wir einfach
mal hier auf die Hilfeseite
gucken. Desktop Cube. Wir haben das
den ganzen Kampel noch offen gehabt.
Extension. Was sind denn
Desklets? Ah so
Widget Geschichten. Ok
da bin ich ja eh kein großartiger
Fan von.
Was Control Alt
Up?
Das ist hier
Desktop Cube.
Sollen wir mal kurz gucken.
Nice. Super.
Does not work. Oh.
Control Alt Left
Right.
Ja da switch ich vor M's mit. Das ist natürlich blöd.
Das ist
schon. Ok das
funktioniert nicht.
Also das ist dann wird
dieses Extension Zeug wohl auch sehr
stiefmütterlich behandelt weil
es macht jetzt auf mich nicht den Eindruck
als gibts da viel.
Wisst ihr
eine Sache die ich tatsächlich benutzen würde
wenn irgendeine gute Distribution
auf Compets
wieder mal aufbaut.
Oder Compets weiterentwickelt und das verwendet.
Compets war einfach das geilste überhaupt.
Aber irgendwie gibts
dann immer richtig.
Compets war einfach das beste.
Da konntest du die geilsten
Sachen machen auf dem Desktop.
Unter anderem Wobbly Windows.
So also da gucken wir mal ob wir
Steam finden.
Über diesen. Wie hieß das Ding?
Packages oder sowas?
War das das?
Ih Synaptik. Alter wusste ich gar nicht das es das noch gibt.
Ähm
Software hieß das glaube ich einfach.
Software meiner Meinung nach.
So gucken wir mal ob wir da drüber Steam finden.
Rund 30.000
Mal Steam.
Steam
FlatHub Igitt.
Package.
Install. Intel
Ja unbedingt die brauche ich.
Ganz klar.
Intel Treiber.
Aber gut ey ist doch
nice das es das im Package Manager
gibt.
Ist schonmal deutlich angenehmer
als unter Windows den Krempel zu installieren.
Über KDE
Ne über Compets.
Weil du konntest Compets auch mit KDE benutzen.
Aber ich versteh
nicht. Alter das Frontrendering von
Steam man.
Ich versteh nicht wie sie sowas
geil die hatten sowas geiles
going quasi so
so 2008
9, 10
11 vielleicht noch rum.
Was
Linux Desktops anging mit Compets.
Und das
haben die einfach die haben sich da komplett zerfahren
wieder in so richtig
Linux typisch einfach die Sache
wieder in Sand gesetzt.
50.000 Objekte äh
Projekte geforkt 50.000 verschiedene
Window Manager Standards.
Und im Endeffekt ist Compets
dann mit untergegangen.
Das wäre eigentlich das Ding gewesen.
Das hätte auch die Leute überzeugt.
Boah also Steam und Wobbly Windows
hat so seine Probleme.
Wie beendet man Steam jetzt eigentlich
wenn man hier unten keine Icons hat?
Oder ist wenn ich zuklicke
Steam automatisch wieder
Ja ok Steam.
Vielleicht läuft das auch gar nicht im Hintergrund gerade.
Ne anscheinend
gar nicht.
Wobbly Windows nervt dich. Nein Wobbly
Scheiß Leute Wobbly Windows ist das
einzig wahre
allerbeste Wobbly Windows.
Was haben wir hier sonst noch?
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Leute ich muss jetzt gleich pennen.
Ich würde sagen wir gucken uns das wirklich ausführlich morgen
oder so nochmal fertig an.
Natürlich aller wichtigste Chat
Test was haben wir
für Default Backgrounds.
Und was war das?
Ach so das waren diese komischen
Diese komischen
Widgets.
Fast
Das ist ja fast ein bisschen
wie Windows
Vista war das doch mit dieser komischen
Uhr oder?
Kann das Sekunden
Pm
Und jetzt?
Ja
Es funktioniert nur das wir nicht
ähm sondern das wir Stunde
haben wollen.
Pm war aber nicht so.
Vielleicht.
Warum ist das jetzt auf einmal
rot im Hintergrund? Irgendjemand ein Plan?
Haben wir es
haben wir es kaputt gemacht?
Ach ne das ist weil ich in den
Settings drinne bin.
Ah.
Gar nicht mehr so übel.
So die Hintergründe sind jetzt
eher nicht so geil.
Was haben wir da?
Weihnachtliche Stimmung.
Norwegen
Ach guck mal.
Die Schweiz.
Gibt es ein paar.
Ist mir alles zu hell.
Ah Grass.
Grass ist gut das kann man lassen.
Retro.
Äh Grass.
Also
An sich macht es auf
Ich glaube wir sollten uns das wirklich mal in Ruhe fertig
angucken.
Ähm
Es macht jetzt auf den ersten Blick wirklich
einen ganz nice Eindruck.
Muss ich sagen.
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht das zu empfehlen.
Ich verstehe immer noch nicht genau warum man nicht
damals mit Compets weitergemacht hat.
Da war wirklich Desktop Linux
so 2007, 2008 rum
waren Desktop Linux wirklich
auf einem guten Weg mit Compets.
Weil es hatte halt was wo so
es war so ein richtiger richtiger Hingucker
wo dann auch Leute gesagt haben
Oh geil Alter das will ich auch.
Und sind damit in Kontakt gekommen.
Diese typische Linux Geschichte wieder.
50 Projekte
und irgendwie ist dann irgendwann ist Compets
halt untergegangen. Klar man hat
so einige der sinnvollen Funktionen ja jetzt auch
in die Standard Windows Manager übernommen.
Aber was mit Compets möglich
war war einfach geil.
Von Wobbly Windows von diesem komischen Würfel.
Dann konntest du deine Fenster abfackeln
lassen.
War nice und ich will nicht wissen wo das heute wäre.
Wäre das weiterentwickelt.
Die wollen die Gimmicks
nicht jeden Tag. Ja und?
Die wollen die Gimmicks nicht benutzen.
Du kannst ja Compets auch so konfigurieren
dass es einfach nur
eine grafisch beschleunigte Oberfläche
war und sowas.
Aber du konntest halt so cooles Zeug machen.
Ja Wayland und Compets
kannst du eh vergessen.
Kannst du in Wayland Wobbly Windows
machen?
Mit irgendwas?
Bestimmt oder?
Ja Compets es wird nicht mehr wirklich viel gemacht.
Das sieht man auch an den Compets.
Leider nicht.
Ich glaube die haben die Compets reloadet
oder wie das hieß.
Also ohne Mist so blöd es klingt.
Ich glaube Ubuntu von 2011
oder so mit Compets noch integriert
dürfte auch heute noch optisch
also gemoddet
ja das man es ein bisschen optisch cool macht
eines der größten Hingucker
Distributionen schlecht überhaupt sein.
Also es macht
einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Max FPS LOL
Warum?
Du meinst weil du den Stream gefunden hast
wahrscheinlich.
Schön das du deinen Weg her gefunden hast.
Aber ich bin gar nicht Max FPS.
Ich bin ja Wobblors.
Wobbly Windows Effekt in Hyperland
Siehste?
Ich sag es euch.
Das war einfach
Superior damals.
Kein Wobbly Windows Effekt
hier selbst für neue hippe
Window Manager.
Wobbelt nichts.
Wobbelt was.
Beste.
Wobbly Windows einfach
Wir gucken uns das
Leute wir gucken uns das morgen in Ruhe mal fertig an.
Ich glaube da gibt es echt noch einiges zu entdecken
und ich muss ja wenigstens wissen
was ich den Leuten als Einsteiger Distribution
empfehle. Bei der Gelegenheit können wir uns dann
auch mal Mate angucken. Vielleicht geht ja Mate
plus Compets. Alter das
das wäre extrem
Pogu. Ja Compets
reloaded.
Ja da gibt es kaum noch Compets beim ordentlichen
Compets und beim
reloaded
Da sind wir ja gerade.
Guck mal da gibt es kaum noch
kaum noch Compets drinne.
Da tut sich nichts mehr. Seriously.
Das ist dead.
Das ist
dead das Projekt.
Was halt echt bitter
ist Compets war das beste
was es je gegeben hat
auf dem Linux Desktop
und das wäre meiner Meinung nach
echt so ein Ding gewesen.
Was der ganzen Sache
zumindest auf dem Desktop mit zum Durchbruch
hätte helfen können.
Aber
tja. Da starten
sie sich halt selbst den Weg.
Für mich heutzutage ist es egal.
Ich benutze i3. Ist eh nichts mit
Composition großartig und wobbly Windows.
Aber das wäre schon cool gewesen.
Der Ubuntu Installer ist neu. Ja nur der
grafische Installer habe ich gelesen.
Also der grafische Installer
scheint mir neu zu sein.
Leute wir gucken uns morgen den Rest an.
Es war auf jeden Fall, ich weiß nicht was es vorgeschlagen hat
aber ich muss sagen es war eine sehr gute Idee
das vorzuschlagen
und
ich muss bis jetzt sagen mir gefällt das
von den Sachen die wir uns angeguckt haben
so Top 3 mäßig
bis jetzt. Also es macht
einen durchdachten Eindruck und es ist
auch nicht so wie bei vielen Projekten wo man dann
in 3 Optionen
klickt und denkt ah ok sieht auf den ersten
Blick gut aus aber ist auch nicht durchdacht oder so.
Das Standardzeug macht wirklich
einen guten Eindruck.
Ich muss ins Bett Leute.
Wir sehen uns. Machts gut
bis morgen. CU